sans quesada doit-il rendre ses gains
c'est la question que vous a posé et
qu'on vous pose sur les réseaux sociaux
sur twitter notamment
vous pensez qu'il doit rendre ses gains
et vous pensez que dans alors on n'a
jamais trop roland perez qui étaient
avec nous vous allez nous dire s'il doit
rendre ses gains ou pas merci regarde
toujours très élégant et on vous
retrouve d'ailleurs dans la quotidienne
de crime aux côtés de jean marc
morandini ça cartonne à la crim la
quotidienne sur nrj 12
tous les jours en début d'après-midi et
bravo monsieur c'est un des traits au
succès de la rentrée daniel vous vous
avez assisté à des émissions des 12
coups de midi pendant que christian
quesada a été candidat eh ouais alors
vous le qualifiez bien au début où
l'aînée bien et après ça s'est gâté qui
s'est passé ben oui après un bon bain au
début comme tout dans les jeux ça va et
après quoi il peut par petit peu ben
c'est vous dire qu'il était si intense
yeux et voilà pourquoi il voulait on
change aussitôt qu'on gagne beaucoup
d'argent vous daniel vous voulez qu'ils
rendent l'argent parce que oui tout vous
sentez trail c'est ça ben oui parce
qu'on est quand même dans le public on a
téléphoné souvent importe il pour les
jeux et puis arrivé là bas c'est plus du
tout ce à quoi je veux dire que on a été
quand même trahi quand même dans le
public
alors vous avez votre avis après on aura
la réponse de roland perez est ce qu'il
doit rendre les jeux s'il est condamné
au ski doit rendre les gains s'il est
condamné ou pas vous allez réveiller
vous pensez qu'ils ne doit pas enlever
c'est en fait de questions totalement
différente ce type est abject ces actes
sont odieux pour autant il a gagné dans
un jeu qui n'a absolument rien à voir
et lors d'une compétition donc à ce
moment-là tous ceux qui ont fait des
actes délictueux et qui par ailleurs se
trouve sur un jeu qui ont porté de
l'argent il faudrait qu'ils rendre leur
argent ce sont deux choses complètement
différentes
moi ce qui m'importe c'est que ce type
qui est en ce moment en attente de son
jugement soit jugé pour les actes qu'il
a commis soient jugés sévèrement alors
le reste ça ne me regarde pas fait
partie des candidats qui ont remporté
une des plus grosses sommes en français
on a envie de revenir ne lui envie aussi
de revenir sur les candidats qui ont
gagné beaucoup d'argent en jeu télé en
2004 via maris qui a gagné la somme d'un
million de roy qui veut gagner des
millions avec jean pierre foucault c'est
très très rare
regardez
en 1908 audio le marathon se dispute
pour la première fois sur 42 km 195 vous
avez le choix donc entre versailles et
paris le pirée à athènes
windsor et londres peas et vous je vous
dis la réponse est où ils auraient
londres
[Musique]
whissell
c'est la seule candidate à avoir
remporté millions d'euros dans le jeu et
embrasse fort sa famille puisqu'elle est
décédé neuf ans après sa victoire à
l'âge de 66 ans vraiment on pense à fin
mai alors ya eu aussi le 16 juin 2016
cécile et philippe qui ont battu un
record dans money drop sur tf1 il avait
remporté 260 mille euros c'est le record
historique de 160000 euros d'amendé de
reprogrammer vous avez posé la plus
grosse somme jamais misé dans money drop
260 milles euros sur fernand de magellan
allez vous battre les trappes de money
drop et repartir avec 260 milles euros
vérifions
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jamais gagné dans la négoce de vue
dijon alors qu'ils sont quesada lui il a
gagné 800 ans 1000 euros de gains au
total 800 9392 pour être précis et 209
mille 392 euros de cadeaux qu'il a
remporté cette voiture et cette
télévision
cette étoile mystérieuse découverte qui
ont fait gagner plusieurs ordinateurs
des téléphones portables alors sa
première apparition c'était le 4 juillet
2016 et très rapidement il a atteint les
100 mille euros de gains regardez
c'était le 22 juin 18 et d'évasion de
christian notre maître 2010 serial
degemer de bonnes réponses et détenteur
d'une carte cagnotte de 80 du 1896
d'euros elles sont des nations
vous pouvez passer aujourd'hui le cap de
100 mille euros de gains et de cadeaux
[Musique]
alors on va voir son associé comme ça
donc la cent mille euros
ceux qui pensent qu'ils doivent rendre
les gains hier jean michel maire oui moi
je trouve pas ce que valent elles
indiquent ces deux choses complètement
différentes à la fois ces crimes
et puis sa participation aux jeux sauf
qu'une partie une partie de ses cris les
affecte les gains des jeux est notamment
les ordinateurs qui ont permis de faire
son réseau et de le voir du dit fier de
recevoir des photos ou d'en diffuser
dans le trouble a il ya une collusion
des deux événements qui sait que bah
déjà s'il a un tout petit peu d'honneur
maquis rendre ont de l'argent à dépenser
que de rendre l'argent mais franchement
là moi je suis ça me dégoûte terre les
biens ça me dégoûte tellement le ce
qu'est ce qu'elle fait ce monsieur
l'argent sert bien d'avoir de la liberté
et honnêtement il va pas il va pas aller
20 ans en prison malheureusement cette
sortie des rames à présent on n'ira pas
20 ans 16 ans est malheureusement alors
soit il est soit il est hors de lui il
faut qu'il soit il reste enfermé soi et
il est fou et il faut aussi qu'ils
restent enfermés avec de l'argent il va
effectivement pouvoir se libérer au
pouvoir faire des eaux par partir en
voyage et honnêtement j'aimerais qu'il
ait une grosse amende parce qu'on pourra
pas lui retirer parce que légalement il
les a gagné une grosse amende qui le
prive de fait cet argent alors donc là
c'était les 100000 euros très vite
l'ascension continue pour christian
cassette caisse à la catin les 6000
euros de gains le 3 novembre et sa cote
de popularité augmente en même temps que
signent un bien sûr
cet ex
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la première
et je le verrai
dites vous êtes à la veille
ici des ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous passez donc la barre aujourd'hui
fatidique aujourd'hui trois de ventes
des six cent mille euros
une fois de plus c'est mérité alors vous
pensez qu'ils ne doit pas rendre
l'argent christine kelly d'abord moi je
pense qu'il ne doit pas rendre l'argent
parce qu'il semblerait qu'il élève seule
ses deux enfants
premièrement donc déjà pour les deux
enfants faut qu'il les garde
juridiquement je vois pas pourquoi est
ce qu'on va lui prendre quelque chose
qu'il a gagné légalement après
moralement
et oui comme ça serait bien qu'il
donnait une salariée exact parce que
alors donc j'ai du coup bien c'est assez
compliqué difficile comme situation ggf
a l'habitude de faire juge comme ça ni
même avocat du diable et on a vite
watteau qui sont en moi à sa place
oui je sais pas ni son avocat ni lé
défendre on y est pour ni contre on va
voir la réponse de l'avocat doit être sa
place j'aurai deux mois même agi en
conséquence
j'aurais de moi même il faut pas
mélanger le temps du jeu et le temps
judiciaire
s'il n'a pas triché ce qu'il a gagné il
la vraie il a vraiment mouillé le
maillot pour gagner avec ça il ya pas le
lui reprocher c'est même le seul truc
qu'on peut pas lui reprocher et
maintenant il ya le temps judiciaire où
il a écopé pour ce qu'il a fait faut pas
tout mélanger et maintenant c'est bien
comme dit jean michel s'il pouvait faire
un don et si on pouvait voilà c'est la
moindre des choses alors l'éthique et la
morale oblige je vois qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui réagissent sur
cette question sur les réseaux sociaux
peut-il rendre les gains ou pas ça ça
divise beaucoup oui l'éthique et la
morale exige qu'ils rendent l'argent
pour moi c'est de la salubrité publique
et je déplore que le règlement de
l'émission que j'ai consulté je les lui
n'intègre pas ce cas de figure il n'y a
que deux cas où vous devez rembourser si
vous trichez pendant l'émission et si
vous avez six mois avant l'émission
participer à un autre jeu qui sera
diffusé c'est arrivé une fois il ya une
candidate qui était chez nagui chez
reitmans par nagui l'a obligé à
rembourser
non c'est arrivé une fois j'ai fait
exactement mais sinon rien dans le
règlement de l'obliger il faut changer
le règlement alors le 13 janvier 2017
christian quesada est éliminée du jeu le
dans le lendemain il revient dans
l'émission pour toucher son chèque de
plus de 8
son 1000 euros regarde quel chanteur de
rock américain était l'époux de dita von
teese de 2005 à 2007
marilyn manson et je le déclare
aujourd'hui participatio tuer
à des premiers clients
14 janvier 800 9392
google
et de giallo maurizia
alors ira l'ira qui m'arrive pas rendre
là j'entends gilles en fait vous allez
voir le résultat du sondage moi
effectivement la loi et mahé lamorère
sont difficilement compatibles
alors on n'a qu'à demander harvey ou en
chine par exemple de rendre tout
l'argent qu'il a gagné avec ses films ou
à bertrand lors c'est le producteur
aéronautique qui a été attaqué pour me
deux balances ton port ou à bertrand
cantat le chanteur de noir désir de
rendre tout l'argent qu'il a gagné avec
ses albums pour l'assassinât de marie
trintignant décès de bonne de bondex
donc je pense qu'il faut il faut pas il
faut pas tout mélanger en revanche
effectivement que cet argent soit
bloquée pour qu'ils soient versés à ses
enfants par exemple à leur majorité ou
converse à cet argent par exemple à des
à des oeuvres caritatives qui lutte
contre la pédopornographie évidemment
bien sûr mais on ne peut pas à mon avis
se substitue à la justice et prendre son
argent de fait comme ça alors maître
roland perez je me tourne maintenant
vers vous est-ce que s'il est condamné
est-ce qu'il doit rendre l'argent en
fait la question qui se pose c'est qui
peut d'abord réclamé la restitution de
cet argent
est-ce que c'est véritablement la
production cachet est ce que c'est le
parquet le procureur de la république
qui lors de l'audience va demander la
restitution de ces sommes à quel titre
peut-il le faire
en réalité se pose un problème en fait
contractuels soient effectivement et
vous l'avez dit soit dans le règlement
du jeu il était prévu que le passé
judiciaire les antécédents judiciaires
la moralité du candidat la probité du
candidat soit une condition
substantielle à la participation de ce
jeu et auquel cas s'il a menti bas il ya
une unité du contrat il a il aurait dû
restituer cette somme le procureur de la
république lui va se pencher uniquement
sur à la fois le passé judiciaire pour
lesquels il a déjà été condamné peut
parvenir il a déjà écopé de peines
sérieuse j'imagine à l'époque pour cette
pédopornographie donc on va juste avoir
un regard sur son casier judiciaire
au regard de ce qu'il vient de faire là
est peut-être te condamné plus
lourdement
mais je pense que sincèrement en l'état
à la fois du contrat passé avec la
production est en l'état la législation
pénale
il ya très peu de chances pour que pour
que l'argent puisse être restituée et et
que la chaîne ou même le producteur
puisse obtenir gain de cause
est ce qu'il ya une amende au pardon oui
bien sûr on va avoir une amende qui peut
aller jusqu'à 75 mille euros d'axa est
ce que le procureur peut demander par
exemple que cet argent soit bloquée pour
ses enfants
non et ce ne soit qu'à ses enfants
non non non parce qu en fait c'est
encore une fois il va être jugé
uniquement pour les faits et les fesses
et la pédo pornographique qui est pas en
lien direct on va dire avec la mission
si on y voit un lien direct
peut-être qu'il y aura une demande de
confiscation peut-être du matériel qui a
servi notamment ses ordinateurs qui ont
pu servir au à la une espèce de
messagerie électronique sans contact et
sait jamais mais sincèrement non je
prend alors le procureur ne pourra pas
aller jusqu'à la route il n'y a aucune
chance qu'on lui demande de rire et de
redonner les gains vous ça vous ça vous
dérange daniel leur donner les liens
d'un ticket qui gardent les gains ben
non il faudra kerecki rang dans l'est
soit une association ou le soir
on est déçu parce que vous oui quand
même vous êtes une grande estime
oui je vais souvent aux deux comédies
mais bon après là on a tous un froid
aussi bien tous les les personnes mais
moi je veux dire que j'ai eu d'autres
infos vous donne j'ai eu ce matin le
grand patron de la production du jeu est
vraiment jolie et j'oserais s'enfonce
vraiment sincère il n'a eu aucun message
aucun appel aucun signal et je sais
quelqu'un vraiment très sérieux et c'est
quelqu'un en qui j'ai plutôt confiance
et je peux vous dire je pense que la
production n'était pas du tout au
courant malgré les rumeurs qu'on peut
entendre ici et là que vous dire ce
qu'on entend certaines rumeurs qui
disent que la production était au
courant il me l'a vraiment assuré et je
vois la chose que je peux me tromper
mais en tout cas ce n'est pas le
contraire
oui mais je lui fasse et confiance c'est
qu'il entend assez bien voilà que je
connais bien et je pense qu'il n'était
pas du tout au courant et c'est
quelqu'un de très intègre voilà je pense
vraiment que la production ne le savais
pas dans le cadre de sa défense en
revanche son avocat avec l'accord
évidemment du candidat enfin de monsieur
que ça là il pourrait proposer de
restituer une partie de ces sommes à une
association de protection des mineurs ou
à sa participera à sa rédemption sa
participera à en fait à voilà a des
circonstances atténuantes sur les faits
qui lui sont reprochés comme il s'est
dit meurtri ça serait encore on va
attendre alors dans une interview
accordée à femme actuelle christian
quesada a révélé ce qu'ils comptaient
faire lui de tout cet argent parce que
on sait pas encore voilà sinon s'il a
toujours les 800 millions vous allez en
avant par les vigiles je vous rappeler
guy voilà non il est souvent dit ça
m'arrive à 52 ans
heureusement parce qu'à 25 ans je crois
que j'aurais pu péter un peu les plombs
bien évidemment je veux consacrer une
grande partie cet argent à mettre mes
enfants à l'abri me faire un petit
plaisir en achetant certainement une
maison et puis voyager voilà je suis pas
quelqu'un de spécial mans dépensier je
vais pas m'acheter une rolex à 20000
euros alors que j'ai même pas une kelton
à 5
et puis je ne vais pas non plus flambé
dans du high tech puisque j'ai déjà tout
gagné dans les étoiles
donc voilà donc je mettrais zone avec
cet argent me faire plaisir
le petit plaisir que je me suis fait ces
jeux voilà déjà planifié un voyage au
japon donc voyage de quasiment trois
semaines au japon où on va bien bien
bien décompresser bien
[Musique]
gilles alors à propos des gains
justement vous savez que ça a mis
longtemps pour que l' enquête aboutisse
à son arrestation
parce que c'était compliqué parce qu'ils
voyageaient bout exactement il était
souvent à l'étranger
c'est donc je n'ai pas les sommes
exactes mais il ya eu énormément de
voyages dispendieux je crois qu'a eue au
japon je suis sûr qu'ils aient du talent
n'ont eu d'autres pays
ça fait que aujourd'hui même si on le
forçait à restituer il n'y aurait plus
la somme qu'il a gagné pas mal d'argent
m'a-t-on dit a été dépensé alors on n'a
pas d'info benjamin ballon ressort sur
sa nettement aujourd'hui maintenant il
ya l'application la production vous
dites que il savait pas moi je les crois
bien les choses je connais bien et
passionnant dont vous parlez c'est
incroyable que pendant six mois il ya eu
pas vu un seul signal
voilà moi je veux bien croire après je
pense sincèrement et ça me ramène à ce
qu aux convives et nous serons sur la
télé réalité où il y avait quand même
une enquête qui était fait et au tout
début qui était très sérieuse il faut
absolument qu'en télévision maintenant
ça que ça sert vraiment d'exemple et
qu'on soit sur ou moins de la moralité
des candidats alors s'ils ont tous fait
des conneries mais des choses très
graves comme la pédophilie etc
le viol c'est ces gens là ne peuvent pas
avoir accès à la télévision ce sont des
exemples les gens les regardent les gens
comme madame il avait des raisons adulé
et c'est terrible ce que ça fait comme
comme come on come ravages derrière
alors on a on avait pu le début de la
feria jour luc reichmann qui est très
discret il avait réagi à la sphère le 28
mars dernier sur ces réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui il est ressorti du silence
jean luc il a accordé une interview à tv
mag est illettrée cash
quand on lui demande si la production
était au courant il dit je vous invite à
poser la question directement à endemol
donc là la boîte de prod on prend les
paramètres tels qu'ils viennent et on
s'interroge
je crois qu en toute lucidité nous avons
tous intérêt à visualiser l'avenir pour
que ça ne se reproduise plus jamais
chaque fois chacun doit prendre ses
responsabilités
donc notre côté donc je voulais dire on
a contacté voilà la production et ils
nous disent affirme qu'il n'ya pas eu
aucun signe aucun signalement de la part
des téléspectateurs
on apprend aussi dans l'article du
parisien que les journalistes ne sont
pas les bienvenus aux abords du studio
de l'émission interdiction d'entrée
c'est trop chaud ici c'est le vigile des
12 coups de midi qu aurait dit ça voilà
et donc voilà je dis la production je
pense vraiment qu'ils sont sincères jean
luc reichmann je pense sincère également
voilà donc c'est vrai que dans cette
histoire
voilà on a tous
été berné les gains doit-il les rendre
ou pas géraldine voulait réagir là tu me
suis-je voir le sondage on dit juste que
quand même y avait quelqu'un de la
production qui avait fait supprimer le
blog à monsieur quesada oui c'est vrai
voilà c'est vrai que ça après voilà oui
après c'était un s'était pas que c'est
un blog un petit peu douteuse c'était
parfait olé olé voilà déjà